what is going on elena i have been
married to my husband
for a little over 20 years now
and we have
been experiencing over the course of our
time together
um a lot really
problems with intimacy in our
relationship
um both emotional and physical
intimacy and i'm wondering how i can
get him to see
a sex therapist with us okay
so tell me be a little more specific
walk me through some of the
the challenges um i
i don't know what our
hey hold up elena hold on yes we're
super into this already
so it's all good you're like i can be
like
so and we're all in you just go for it
okay hey listen there's like seriously
16 people that listen to this podcast
at the most right four of them are my
brother he just has like
four different monitors open anyway it's
either 16
or a million or so either way it's all
good so
we're we're in it go for it so
it's just i don't find our sex life very
fulfilling okay what does that mean so
that
looks like he's not good in bed he's not
adventurous
you ask him for things and he says i'm
not doing that like what do you mean
i feel like he shuts me down when i tell
him what i need from him
and it creates a cycle where i avoid
yeah which creates another situation
where he
angry at me for avoiding and you're
getting a weird that weird
sucky uh marriage dance right so
yeah and i want to break the cycle i
love him dearly i want
for us to be happy yeah and
i i need i need to break this cycle
somehow
and i i'm at a loss for what to do well
i love
love love your spirit like you're making
my heart feel
good that you're invested in this this
is so awesome
um so when you say you tell him what you
need
what do you need i
tell him how i want him to touch me i
tell him what i need
him to say to me um i felt like a
kindred to a caller
in several shows back when
she asked her has
been she felt like she was talking a
different love language than her husband
then that her husband was kind of
shutting her down and i'm like oh oh
that's me
yeah yeah so why does he
why does he shut you down well it
i know that he comes from a
rather traumatic upbringing okay
um he his the nature of his job
is he's exposed to great amounts of
trauma
uh on a regular basis what's that job
he's in law enforcement okay um
and so he
he didn't have the best example of what
a loving relationship looks like
okay uh growing up and
i think that part of that spilled over
into
he didn't really explore his own
sexuality
okay does he believe that
you love him and cherish him and value
him
yes i think so you know sir you think so
no i i'm i know so i tell him regularly
okay so not in the ways that you think
like um and i'm just speaking broad
generalizations here i'm totally
gendering this
nobody write mean things on the internet
but um
like sometimes the trap is i wash his
clothes i make his dinner
i fill in the blank he knows how much i
love him
and that's not always the answer to that
question
and so posed another way
has he ever communicated to to you
here's how i would really feel valued
and loved
and you said sweet i'm all in
he hasn't communicated that to me okay
either verbally or like well even
not so do you love and cherish yourself
i try to okay
so you said you want to be happy
walk me through a picture of what happy
is
that's one of those amorphous words that
ends up the finish line moves on us when
we chase it right
until we finally know what it is
um
for me that would be that we both
feel secure enough in the relationship
that we're not concerned that
the other's gonna leave because of these
problems
so do you think he's gonna leave
i have expressed to him that i am
powerful that he would
okay are you gonna leave
i don't want to that's
an expertly avoidant answer are you
gonna leave
i'm not giving up without a fight okay
that's awesome
i just don't want to be the only one
fighting that's fair
that's fair so when's tell me about the
last time you sat
not down a fight or not in a frustrated
moment but sat down and said
i want our life to have reckless
reckless
rambunctious wild sex i want to be able
to
um be so enmeshed and in love with you
in such a wild way here 20 years into
this thing
that we are tangled up and that i'm
having to hide my phone because of the
things
that you send me that i've asked you to
and vice versa and
and ann but i need some new tools and i
want you to come with me
have you ever had that conversation with
him
not that explicitly no okay
so here's here's the way forward
especially for somebody who's
experienced
um trauma sexual trauma who has a
high traumatic job
and i've been in that same situation
when somebody comes at me especially
with something as sensitive as sex
especially
something as sensitive as my body some
something as sensitive as
me right for people who have experienced
trauma or
work and living trauma are experts at
walls
real quick right he's really good at
that yeah of course
and even better at mirrored walls
so the things you throw at us we can
throw up a wall real quick and it
bounces right back and you end up taking
the brunt of your own complaint right
you feel bad about saying something or
trying to get help with something et
cetera right
and then you feel more lonely and more
lonely to which then i feel lonely
right and then i blame you for my
loneliness and we just get in this weird
circle
so the the way through that
is for you to say really explicitly
we are two decades in and you are the
man that i'm married you're the man that
i love you're the man that i
want to take this our sexual life our
sexual intimacy our sex life don't even
use words like intimacy use words like a
like a
someone who is just ravenously
desiring this guy and say i am ready to
go to a level that both of us don't even
know yet
and i speaking about you i don't have
the tools to get us there
i would love for you to explore this
with me because i'm ready to go
and if he says now i'm good man i'm
going to watch the game
then that's all the answer that you need
right
and if he looks at you like i don't know
another person i don't know one off top
of my head that wouldn't look at their
wife and say
okay i'm a super all in and you can tell
them i'm scared about how this is gonna
work this is gonna be
awkward for us and i'm nervous about it
and i'm super super all in
but i want to go get some tools and if
he's in law enforcement like every cop
i've ever met in my life and i've known
a bunch bunch of them he's going to say
i'm not going to some therapist whatever
then you can say i'm going to and i
would love it if you came
and at the end of the day that's the
best best you can do and you can really
double down on
healing your heart learning some new
tools and then letting him see the
benefit of
these new tools you're learning and my
gut tells me he'll follow right along
with you
i know a lot of brave law enforcement
folks who get over that initial hurdle
about counseling get over that initial
hurdle
about therapy and then all of a sudden
their entire
world is different because they learn a
whole new language
on how to be scared how to say i don't
know how to
put their guard down take off that
bulletproof vest and then the vest
underneath that vest right which is the
one that protects their soul
and say all right if we're going to do
this let's go all
in right does that sound exciting or no
exciting and scary yes tell me about
scary
um
the scary is you know what if he just
says no yes and that's me and that's my
that's on me no no no no elena that's on
every
human in the world
every single person listening to this or
watching this just went
yes because every relationship whether
it's two weeks or 20 years is a risk
and every time you say hey there's one
more thing
i learned more about my wife we've been
together for over 20 years
dating and married i learned a lot about
her this year and she learned a lot
about me that i didn't know
and she didn't know whoa right
and so it's a risk it's a super risk and
it's scary
but what's the alternative
it's just to sit there and continue to
let the air slowly drain out of this
thing
you see where it's headed you know where
it's headed
he knows where it's headed so at some
point somebody has to turn and face this
fire and say i'm gonna be the one and
you said it here
right here to me you said i'm not going
down without a fight
and the beautiful thing here is the
fight is more awesome sex
that's the fight i'm i'm all in somebody
walking through the lobby just looked in
and was like whoa what are y'all talking
about
this more awesome set right
about being fully known about finally
being loved in a way that you go
yes and that he goes whoa what have i
been missing
right you don't sound like you're all in
on that
i i am i am
hey listen i don't know what you do for
a living do not be an actress because
you are not selling this
why did this suddenly get scary no
you've known him for two decades why
does he get scary all of a sudden
i don't know it it's not scary in that
it's it's just
i'm i'm hoping he's going to go along
for the ride
okay so let me tell you this you ready
don't hope
you've got to go if you go into this
conversation with one foot already out
just in case
you can feel it you can feel it you can
know
this man she's she says she loves me but
she's hedging her bets
you've been married for 20 years
either there's something else here that
you're not telling me about
or you got to just jump and by the way
man man if you're in love with somebody
for this long and they're not all the
way in the pool man everybody in the
room knows it your kids know it your
friends know it
and especially that little six inch gap
between the two of you in bed feels like
a hundred miles apart
at some point one of you and it sounds
like you has got to just say enough
i want this to be ravenous and reckless
i want to be so obnoxiously in love with
you that
literally our kids are embarrassed they
are
embarrassed and i'm super okay with that
because my life is not making sure my
kids aren't embarrassed
my life is making sure that i slide in
like i said about those two women's at
the top of the hour here to begin the
show
we slide into the end of our lives with
no tread left on the tires i want no
conversations left
had i want to have fully risked
everything
to that person that i said i do to i
risked everything went all
in and yeah elena he could say dude i'm
i'm sorry i'm out and god that would
suck
but if that's the case he's already out
now right
and then you get a clean cut and you can
go figure out what's next instead of
just slowly the air leaving this thing
but go all in tell them you're going to
learn some new tools tell me you're
going to go figure some things out and
you want them to be along for the ride
because both of you are going to benefit
everyone around you is going to benefit
his work's going to benefit you're going
to ben everything gets better
when a couple is all in on each other
all in
and i'm excited for your heart and your
soul and the fact that you said the
magic words i'm not going down without a
fight
and if all of our fights were about more
better sex god almighty what a great
world that would be